[Musik]
so wie beide wollen apps hin bilden und
depression sie die angeboten bekomme
sollte auch nutzen um die mit sich
[Musik]
ich kann neues ländern und mal ein
bisschen vertiefen und das bringt viel
bei der firma prüfen
sie alle wollen eine gute ausbildung
acht monate lang begleiten wir sie auf
ihrem weg zur chemie prüfung so herzlich
willkommen im gymnasium unterstrass zum
aufnahme prozedere von chagall 99
bedeutet das ist das neue jahr dass wir
das dieses programm führen
an schweizer gymnasien stammen weniger
als zehn prozent der schüler aus
fremdsprachigen familien das schulhaus
unter straße in zürich hat vor zehn
jahren das projekt chancengerechtigkeit
durch arbeit an der laufbahn kurz
chagall lanciert es geht für uns ein
stück weit um gerechtigkeit es hat in
diesem laden junge menschen die hätten
das potenzial und sie haben den
arbeitswillen sie sind einsatzfreudig
und mit ein bisschen mehr unterstützung
können sie schulisch erfolg haben können
eine gute lehre machen kanal
berufsmittelschule machen
begabte jugendliche von migranten
familien mit niedrigen einkommen werden
auf die prüfung für die mittelschulen
vorbereitet man weiß aus der forschung
natürlich dass es für ein kind mit
migrationshintergrund fremdsprachig
enorm schwierig ist in eine höhere
klasse eingestuft zu werden gleiche
leistung viereinhalb wenig lehrer heiße
und mein vater jurist ist und die mutter
primarlehrerin beide aus der schweiz
dann werde ich selbstverständlich in die
sekundarschule eingestuft aber dass
männer aus dem kosovo beide eltern nur
in hilfsberufen betätigung der deutschen
sprache nicht mächtig hat diese chance
nicht
[Musik]
ich habe mit unseren direktor über meine
man meine zukunft am gymnasium
unterstrass gesprochen und auf einmal
hat er mir ein mäppchen übergeben
darauf stand chagall und ich war damals
spannender weise die einzige person mit
migrationshintergrund sowohl im lehr
währungs schüler korpus der ganzen
schule und er meinte du wirst eigentlich
der mann dafür schaust dir mal an wir
brauchen eine operative leitung die
eltern von stefan market beide zahnärzte
kamen vor rund 50 jahren aus slowenien
in die schweiz
ich hatte einfach das glück dass ich aus
einem elternhaus kam dass mir eine
bildungskarriere ermöglichen konnte aber
ich bin natürlich in den späten
siebzigern in den 80er jahren
konfrontiert worden damit was es heißt
wirklich ausländer zu sein in der
schweiz
was das heißt einfach anders zu sein was
es heißt in einer form nicht nicht
wirklich dazuzugehören
in diesem jahr wurden rund 40
schülerinnen und schüler von ihren
lehrern empfohlen die bereitschaft
freizeit zu opfern lern wille und
motivation gehören zu den wichtigsten
aufnahmekriterien
anders als in den meisten anderen
kantonen darf im kanton zürich nur ans
gymnasium wer die aufnahmeprüfung
schafft matthias ist seit drei jahren in
der schweiz
sein vater ist schweizer und lebt in
bolivien seine mutter ungar in lassen
wir das mal mit den sprachen zusammen du
sprichst jetzt gerade jungs hoch
deutlich
dann hast du dazwischen unzählige sagt
das heißt du kannst doch schweizer dann
sprichst du spanisch englisch und
französisch was möchtest du später mal
machen was stellst du dir so vor
also ich weiß es nicht genau aber falls
die gegend geht da würde ich informatik
lernen und nachher informatica bietet
das machen sonst wenn ich das nicht so
sicher
dann bitten wir dich mal draußen zu
warten
natürlich einfacher war schon mehrfach
vom wachsen
der umgang der polier wir nach ungarn
und dann da das sind zwei jahre die
schweiz also ich finde
mohammed wurde der schweiz geboren seine
eltern kommen aus somalia erzählen es
doch ein bisschen was über dich deine
familie besucht zurzeit die 20 grad im
südosten halten und ich möchte mal in
der ddr studieren was machen beim eltern
ging es mein vater arbeitet was
bearbeitet also geschwister hast du auch
noch ein paar habe ich gesehen oder und
es ist vier geschwistern
[Musik]
mohammed kommt aus somalia in seiner
freizeit hält er sich gerne an der
frischen luft auf und fährt velo oder
skateboard da besucht egal weil er
entweder ingenieur oder arzt werden
[Musik]
[Applaus]
französisch ist ihr lieblingsfach jeden
schwester victoria kommt ebenso aus
kroatien am start programm nimmt sie
teilen weil die medizin studieren und
ärzte werden
von 40 bewerberinnen und bewerbern
wurden schließlich 26 aufgenommen
die eltern dieser jugendlichen stammt
aus 15 ländern
während die einen sich über die aufnahme
beim chagall programm freuen
feiert im juni 2016 eine klasse im
gymnasium unterstrass die matura mit
dabei ist rotary die vor vier jahren
dank chagall den sprung ans gymnasium
schaffte mache bin ich die einzige 300
ich möchte kindern werde will das schon
trau mich seit ich zwei jahre alt bin
und dadurch hat mich ein mini lehrerin
habe versprochen dass ich das handy und
das projekt gibt ich glaube dadurch dass
halte mini ältere die hand hinhält
völlig in der volksschule reicht alles
alleine machen
ich fand's wir als nötig erachtet dass
ich jetzt leben der stützung besucher
zum ski besteht
erster schultag zusätzlich zur
sekundarschule müssen die schülerinnen
und schüler hier am mittwochnachmittag
und am samstagvormittag sechs stunden
für die chemie prüfung lernen
hinzu kommen noch viele stunden
hausaufgaben
[Musik]
wir machen das was wir am samstag
gemacht haben damit beginnen während der
aufstehen wir machen unser kleines
workout genau macht wer trotz allem
ausharrt moral ich die zweite übung in
schwingungen genau achtet darauf dass
ihr euch bitte die finger nicht an den
stühlen an schlägt somit schwingen
während sie sind kein altersheim gut
nächste übung richtig durch kennen
die etwas zu die das vorstellen wie ein
baum oder einen felsen jeden trainings
nachmittag eröffnen wir mit den
sogenannten chagall rom ab das ist ein
appell aufwand verschiedenen übungen die
die schüler gemeinsam machen und lernen
also sie leer erlernen 15 übungen in
einer choreografie in einer abfolge und
damit decken wir eigentlich zwei punkte
ab der erste punkt ist die schüler
mussten sie auf baustellen kommen aus
verschiedenen schulen waren mit am
mittwochmorgen noch in der schule in
einer anderen umgebung und kommt hier
dann zu uns aufs gymnasium
um an dieser aufnahmeprüfung zu arbeiten
und das ist eine art fokussierung der
gruppe aufs gleiche ziel durch diese
übungen und jede diese übungen deckt
bestimmte bereiche ab zum beispiel wenn
ich zu lange am schreibtisch sitze was
kann ich machen wenn man schultern
verspannt sind wenn man nacken weh tut
was kann ich machen wenn ich zu
aufgeregt bin oder zu abgelenkt
normalerweise wären die schule geht dann
hat die lehrperson jahr zwei aufgaben
sie unterrichtet euch sie fördert euch
aber sie setzt auch not versteht ihr
also einerseits fördert sie euch aber
andererseits muss ja auch bewerten wir
sind hier die themen sind hier in der
luxuriösen lage und deshalb nennen wir
sie trainerinnen weil sie euch nicht
benoten müssen sondern sie sind wirklich
für euch da um euch zu helfen und ich
auch also kommt vorbei
wirklich
[Musik]
achtung
und ich habe euch hier ezb
aufgeschrieben für ein pronomen objektiv
und hier ist das nomen und jetzt
schreibe ich einen zweiten satz darunter
deutsch ist die brücke zum schulischen
erfolg janjic weiß aus eigener erfahrung
was ihren schülerinnen und schülern zu
beginn fehlt meistens haben sie viel
wissen
aber es ist vielleicht noch etwas
ungeordnet und dann ist es auch
schwieriger das zur gegebenen zeit
abzurufen
aber fußball ist für die jugendlichen
auch eine gemeinsame erfahrung also sie
sie nicht einfach nur einzelkämpfer hier
sind wir erleben es auch immer wieder
dass eine gemeinschaft eigentlich
entsteht
wir haben in dem feedbacks auch zu sehen
dass schüler sagen sie finden es toll
dass sie hier nicht zb ausgelacht werden
oder es komisch ist wenn sie gewisse
fragen stellen die halt darauf
zurückgehen dass deutsch nicht ihre
muttersprache ist
[Musik]
manchmal habe ich schwierigkeiten also
nichts im deutsch habe ich
schwierigkeiten aber sonst ist es ein
bisschen schwierig manchmal ein ganzes
tag durchzuhalten mit die also wenn man
hat drei verschiedene sprachen manchmal
und dazu kommt noch das zuhause leitung
gar nicht also 45 sprachen wo sich einen
tag benutzen
ich bin zufrieden da also mir fällt nur
meine freunde aus und worden und
manchmal die familie weil sie glaubt man
der größe also ungelöst einfach meine
familie lebt den äckern die andere und
bolivien
also ich sehe sie nicht hoffen
es ist für uns wichtig dass wir immer
ein gutes wissen über der welt dass wir
auch mitdiskutieren können und deshalb
hoffe ich dass ich kann das ich schaffe
das
henri stierlin studierte literatur und
anthropologie während einer
feldforschung in bolivianischen
dschungel lernte sie ihren mann kennen
einen schweizer tierarzt der in bolivien
geboren wurde
nach der trennung gehen sie nach ungarn
später kamen sie ohne deutschkenntnisse
in die schweiz
das war die ich denke das schwierigste
weil ich so gut englisch und spanisch
aber kein deutsch und ich bin nicht
gewöhnt nicht kommunizieren nicht gut
kommunizieren so die erste war natürlich
deutsch lernen aber das ist nicht immer
so einfach dass ich habe gedacht ich
gedacht habe zum beispiel die ordnung
grunde wörter und ich möchte immer
deutsch korrekt sprechen und das stört
mich bisher als dass ich gar nicht eine
super gut deutsch sprechen auch wenn es
sich nicht mehr schlecht sie arbeite
teilzeit in einem sozialprojekt für das
sie eigentlich überqualifiziert ist die
dreiköpfige familie lebt in zürich in
engen wohnverhältnisse
ich denke er ist geräte schweiz
ich sehe dass eine ordnung der mal alle
was klar und super organisiert
ich kann ohne kinder einen reise arbeit
finden wir natürlich dass für mich ein
traum ich mag reise nicht mag meine
arbeit aber ich denke wenn du wann man
entscheidet für eine familie das haut
das kommt auch mit verantwortlichkeit
und in diesem zeit als kinder fast zehn
zentimeter
ich musste entscheiden ob es für mich
oder findet und ich denke in dieser zeit
ich möchte die kinder sie sind wichtiger
was ich im moment ich sage nicht immer
im moment sie brauchen stabilität und
eine gute ausbildung
ich denke matthias will sich ja im
winter schweiz bleiben das klar markiert
er findet das toll und ich keine ahnung
im moment weiß ich nicht dieses programm
das braucht sehr viel mut ihr müsst
durchziehen können und deshalb machen
wir mit euch eine kleine übung und
danach einen kleinen test wird
vielleicht zeigen wenn sie musste danach
muss was wir machen ihr werdet nämlich
lernen einem scharf geschliffenen
samuraischwert auszubauen
mut bedeutet ja nicht dass man keine
angst hat sondern mut bedeutet dass man
trotzdem ruhig bleibt und nach vorne
geht auch wenn man angst hat das
vergisst man gerne
das ding ist wirklich scharf
diese ungewöhnliche mutprobe sei absolut
freiwillig versicherte uns market das
war ein kleiner test was ihr daraus
ziehen sollte ist geht auf die gefahr zu
entspannt durchatmen schwierige prüfung
atmen atem nicht steif
[Musik]
arrangierte und victoria gegenseite
erster sekundarklasse zusammen in die
schule
sie sind beste freundinnen und
unzertrennlich wie sie sagen
victoria kam vor acht jahren mit ihren
eltern aus der slowakei in die schweiz
später wurde das kind tamilischer eltern
in zürich geboren also mit ihnen zu
sprechen sollte schon zu nutzen werden
weil ich spannend von also wir wollten
ins prozess gekommen wird haben sie bei
mir in den mund etwas gemacht und ich
wusste nie was sie genau achten und dann
habe ich mich interessiert was darf wohl
wochen also auch als ich klein war hat
das mit knete zähnen gemacht und tragen
geburten es hat mir spaß gemacht auch
mit kleinen sachen zu arbeiten also mit
den händen so präzise wie ist das
zuhause kannst du zum beispiel zu hause
mit einem haushalt mit einer
hausaufgaben und verträgen mutter helfen
also ich lese einfach die hausaufgaben
alleine will weil es hier nicht alles
verstehen was ich ihnen zeigen und dann
ist es auch schwierig wenn ich alles
ertragen muss und ja dann noch als
lieber alleine oder fragt meine
geschwister und ich könnte mir noch
vorstellen dass für viele schüler das
thema integration eben sehr dominant ist
diesmal dass sie wollen sich anpassen
sie wollen so sein wie die schweizer
kinder
sie müssen schon eine leistung erbringen
und dann kommt auch die schule dazu denn
ist nochmals eine leistung sie sind
schon sehr gefordert dass wie epg
die motivation ist im allgemeinen sehr
gut die allermeisten kapieren
realisierung das dass sie eine eine
chance haben die sie übernehmen können
[Musik]
einmal im jahr lädt die schulleitung
alle ehemaligen schülerinnen und schüler
des programms zum brunch ein
sie fühlen sich weiterhin verbunden mit
der schule unter straße eine gute
gelegenheit für die neuen sich in einer
freundschaftlichen atmosphäre mit den
ehemaligen auszutauschen
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
ganz besonders begrüße ich auch die
schüler und schülerinnen aus basel aus
der wirtschaftsmittelschule da gibt es
ein vergleichbares programm inspiriert
von chagall das nennt sich chancen
schön sei tja da tauscht euch aus
untereinander zum heutigen programm ich
weiß ihr habt alle hunger kleines
logistisches problem einfach einen
hinweis bitte zuerst mal maximal drei
brötchen pro person
weil es wollen alle was haben
guten appetit first come first serve
bis zu nehmen
die sind
ja das team hat mich gebeten doch ein
paar sätze wenn man aus einem anderen
land kommt und in mitteleuropa einzieht
hat man grundsätzlich drei möglichkeiten
vorwärts zu kommen
die erste ist sportler werden
profisportler
da kam mir in den sinn der admin ist mit
unserem kinder in die schule gegangen in
oberwinterthur daraus mir heißt mehmedi
spielt jetzt bei bayer leverkusen und in
der schweizer nationalmannschaft ist
albanisch mazedonisch der admira hat
offenbar so erzählt man es sich bei uns
in oberwinterthur hat offenbar etwas in
der schule gesagt wenn er nicht
rauskommt muss möglichst profifußball
okay das ist tatsächlich eine
möglichkeit der hat es ja geschafft
die zweite möglichkeit ein eigenes
geschäft aufzubauen und es gibt eine
dritte möglichkeit und die heißt eine
gute berufslehre und oder ein studium
aber das bedeutet in der schule gut sein
und das ist kann seine sind der weg den
ihr gewählt habt bildung aber alle weg
ist anstrengend weil ihre nachteile mit
machen müsst ihr müsst euch doppelt
soviel anstrengen weil ja zum beispiel
die sprache die erste herausforderung
ist um überhaupt zu verstehen was es
braucht damit man vorwärts kommt hier in
diesem land und manchmal habt ihr es
auch doppelt schwierig weil die
lehrerinnen und lehrer gar nicht richtig
einschätzen können was ihr alles könnt
weil die sprache eine barriere bildet
ich wünsche euch alles alles gute
[Applaus]
[Musik]
das lehrerseminar unterstrass wurde ende
des 19 jahrhunderts nach evangelischen
grundwerten gegründet es war ein
institut für benachteiligte die schule
verfügt heute über ein gymnasium und ein
lehrer institut die gemeinnützige
private schule wird von einem verein
getragen bis anhin ermöglichen
verschiedene stiftungen gemeinsam das
chagall programm neu sicherte kanton
zürich die vollfinanzierung für die
nächsten vier jahre
die erfolgsquote bei den schülerinnen
und schülern betrug bisher im
durchschnitt rund 70 prozent
chagall ist erfolgreich weil es nicht
einfach nur ein schulisches
förderprogramm ist sondern wir
vermitteln auch lernstrategien und wir
sprechen über motivation aale
grundhaltungen und bieten weitere
ergänzende hilfen wo nötig wir arbeiten
mit kleinen gruppen
das heißt unsere trainerinnen und
trainer können sich von ihren ressourcen
her auf jeden einzelnen jede einzelne
einlassen diagnose tests durchführen und
sind im bilde genau was jeder schüler
was jede schülerin braucht
dasselbe gilt auch für mich dadurch dass
die gruppe klein gehalten ist kann ich
jeden schüler jedes schülern
kennenlernen ich kann gespräche führen
ich kann auch ihre motivation krisen
erkennen es ist überschaubar
[Musik]
mit der zeit wird die doppelbelastung
spürbar
die folge sinkende motivation in dieser
phase für die leitung mehr gespräche mit
den jugendlichen und versucht
herauszufinden wo der schuh drückt
matthias kannst dich setzen also viel
neues in der schule beste was wir also
es gibt noch große schwankungen 3 und
jetzt mehr so vier und fünf und jetzt wo
in mathe okay wenn ich mir die
unterlagen anschaue ist das einfach so
dass das die feedback meldungen von den
trainerinnen wirklich nicht gut sind
weil wenn du diese prüfung oder schaffen
möchtest dann müsstest du noch viel mehr
aber wir sind sehr zufrieden mit dem was
deine haltung betrifft
deine bis respektvoll du bist freundlich
interessiert aber es muss einfach noch
irgendwie was geschehen sei der punkt
ist ganz einfach das was du hier erlebst
mit chagall und schüler das wird später
eine alp achse an einer mittelschule auf
die schule konzentrieren ist eins aber
chagall hilft dir durch dieses tor zu
gehen
aber dann wird so weitergehen zentral
für schalke sind die hausaufgaben du
kannst nur wirklich was profitieren denn
diese hausaufgaben gelöst werden
versetzt dich mal in unsere lage was
würdest du du ist trainer oder trainern
und du siehst dieser schüler ist noch
nicht lange da ist freundlicher ist
interessiert ist intelligent aber er
schafft es gerade so dass er in seiner
schule besser wird aber im schatten
deshalb investiert mehr in die schule
aber hat keine zeit fürs programm
verstehst du was würdest du mit so
jemanden machen
was würdest du jemanden sagen
[Musik]
konzentrieren
vielleicht lassen jetzt ist einfach die
frage was machen wir oder wie geht es
weiter
du hast mir ein paar mal gesagt möchtest
du programm bleiben
okay weil wenn du dich konzentrierst ist
die chance immer noch da das das packst
mohammed
schweizerdeutsch hochdeutsch direkt ich
einfach standort speicher läuft recht
gut wie auch die schulen verbessert
super zunächst lernte geige
so sieht immer mit deinem und die
übrigen kuwait wo man am anfang machen
ja okay und wenig verrückter menschen
die so mit dem noxon nordkorea will muss
ich dann schau dir überflüssig machen
dass gott da oder die hier das ist ein
wunderschöner repetieren mit mir sagt
sagte genau und jetzt müssen wir das und
links gott jetzt bescheid über links
geschleudert das links überreicht den
preis unter druck und den stoff und das
wäre immer mache habe jetzt wenn torres
wird
und das fällt ja nicht groß
[Musik]
deutsch macht an der prüfung 40 prozent
aus ebenso mathematik aber auch da macht
vor allem die sprache schwierigkeiten
dann gibt es einen bereich performen
unsere schüler eher
unterdurchschnittlich das ist beim
bereich der textaufgaben da ist klar
dass unsere schüler probleme haben weil
es ja da vor allem ums verstehen der
deutschen sprache geht also dieser text
kommt ja wie es die rein deutsch
geschrieben
da stehen sie häufig an nicht an den
mathematischen konzepten sondern
einverständnis des deutschen textes
[Musik]
da schickte hat eine zwillingsschwester
und einen bruder der eine berufslehre
macht ihr vater arbeitet das koch ihre
mutter gelernte apothekerin als
hilfskraft das zimmer mit anita meinst
du gibt es momente wo du sagst ich bin
hier eine fremde person oder das spürst
du gar nicht in der schule manchmal
vielleicht ausgeschlossen also ich werde
nicht ausgeschlossen aber dort
vielerorts als fremde
ich weiß nicht einfach so ein beispiel
ja wenn wir gruppen arbeiten machen dann
gibt es manchmal so drei gruppen und
dann ja wir sind dort also meine
kollegen und ich sind da und wenn man zu
dritt arbeiten muss dann ja wissen sie
nicht gerade wenn sie wählen sollen dann
falls ich jetzt nicht bei ihnen darüber
bin dann will ich mich so ein bisschen
ausgeschlossen
die frage ja das ist das meine heimat
ist weil ich ja hier aufgewachsen bin
und freuen
[Musik]
in sri lanka freunde und dann wäre hier
gleichauf mit wird die schweiz aus
dieses ressourcen training was wir heute
machen
das ist ein sehr sehr gut erforscht das
selbstmanagement training und es
ermöglicht euch in schwierigen
situationen ganz an eurem ziel dran zu
sein und was wir machen mit dem
ressourcen training mit diesen bildern
die wir kreiert haben mit diesem motto
sofort mit den bildern die ihr selber
gefunden habt mit denen kann eure gefühl
dass anfangen oder ausweis da geht's hin
lösen
da wollen wir hin und dann haben wir
daraus ein motto gemacht
dieses motto ist wieder sprachlich das
verbindet außer unser gehirn mit unserem
herz wenn wir jetzt die gefühle mal ins
herz setzen was was oft gemacht wird na
wie kopf und herz verbunden also dann
sehen wir schon mal mit diesen in die
gleiche richtung unterwegs
klasse in deutsch und mit mut und voller
energie
reichlich mächtig mein ziel um zauberer
ein lächeln in die herzen der menschen
[Gelächter]
das zeigen so das ist der weg den weg da
fängst du an das sind deine erfolge mit
diesen sterne und das sind die stellen
wo du noch erreichen kommt wo in dir
steckt
und wenn du erfolg hast sachen es zu
weitere standen dann kommst du zu dankt
sie so groß wie die milchstraße verfolge
ich geduldig meinem weg und erkenne
meine möglichkeiten hast du angst vor
der prüfung also nur ein bisschen hatten
nur ein bisschen angst wovor ich glaube
das nicht schaffen ist das größte angst
also das einzige an das größte sprichst
du mit jemandem über deine angst ist
nicht zu schaffen
denkst du schaffst die prüfung oder was
sagen die lehrerinnen und lehrer
was ist dein gefühl so wenn ich so
weitermache
[Musik]
man ist und man bleibt immer schon wenn
man den nachnamen immer angeben muss man
bleibt immer einer von denen und nicht
einer von uns man hört dann einfach auch
bei den schülern wenn sie sich für
lehrstellen bewerten oder mit schwierig
auszusprechenden namen ungewöhnlichen
namen dass da einfach eine gewisse
latente fremdenfeindlichkeit da ist
grundsätzlich ist es ja so dass unsere
gesellschaft wenn sie das potenzial
dieser jugendlichen nicht fährt wird
sich etwas entgehen lässt dann lassen
wir das brachliegen und wir können uns
das einfach nicht leisten wir brauchen
doch alle jungen menschen mit dem
größtmöglichen beitrag an die
gesellschaft den sie leisten können
[Musik]
das was man immer wieder hören und uns
natürlich auch freude macht ist dass es
jugendliche gibt die nur jemanden
brauchen der an sie glaubt und der ihnen
zutraut dass sie ihr ganzes potenzial
abrufen können und schon schaffen sie es
ausgeschüttet
[Musik]
lukas ist sich sogar gleich nach dem
airbus der weltweit größte dankeschön
[Musik]
wie weit ist ausgrenzung für rosa nie
ein thema
die schreiben der lykaner und dann
wirklich verallgemeinert aber verletzt
bin ich jetzt nimmer will will ich das
nimmer mich an einer cola will das
bringt gar nicht da sind so viel energie
weg und das ist es was gibt also ja
[Musik]
sollten wir also
lausanne trifft annina ihre freundin aus
der gymnasiums zeit wie der pflegt sie
auch nach dem abschluss der schule einen
engen kontakt
[Musik]
es muss ja ich bin eine spinne rolle
gesucht
also ich geschrieben habe für
humanmedizin die last für jeden
praktikum
es ist für uns sagen schaffen
herr winter sehr schwierige frage wo ich
verwurzelt bin ich fühle mich aber mehr
als schweizerin will ich da geboren und
aufgewachsen
sagen wir so ich würde nie weg verdacht
das ist definitiv meine heimat zum
wohnen
ich genieße es auch sehr gern ob in zwei
mal wieder in die heimat ska und der
meniskus aber ich bin definitiv dauer
beheimatet werden
wir haben heute die letzte woche vor
sehr großen prüfung
ich habe für euch eine lernkontrolle
vorbereitet aber etwas nicht wo ich
jetzt überprüfen sondern nur wirklich
wechseln könnt wo steht ihr habt ihr
noch lücken moment wie geht's dir so
kurz vor den prüfungen
das ist auch aufgeregt bist du aufgeregt
hast du das gefühl du musst nach etwas
reflektieren im fach deutsch
wirtschaftsgüter einsatz glieder
möchtest du machen ok konntest du deine
deutschen oder verbessern jetzt im
letzten semester ist gegen das chaos
geblieben ist gleich geblieben wer von
euch konnte denn die zeugnisnoten
deutsch verbessern
wie hast du dich verbessern haben mich
auf eine von vier und fünf verbessert
mir gehts hier
nach deiner prüfung vor einer prüfung
der schule richtig gut dann machen wir
doch jetzt diese lernkontrolle zusammen
satria kannst du alle zeitformen
aufzählen dressels präteritum perfekt +
com perfect photo durch zwei sehr danke
könnt ihr mir sagen welche wort hat die
einzige ist die nicht veränderbar ist
publikum ganz wichtig welches schließen
wir zuerst aus welche artikel sorte
berlin
funktionen zuerst präpositionen
deklination ist ja ein bisschen anders
verändert was die konjugation wie
verändern wir die wohnungen von csk und
sie ziehen von kennst du noch den
lateinischen begriff brauchst du sus
welche zwei jahren den worten sind nach
der kliniker radioaktive ihr habt das
auf anhieb richtig gemacht dass ihr habt
jetzt diese worte hat nun wirklich infos
oder könnt ihr euch noch erinnern wir
gar nicht klargekommen seit mit der
deklination ganz am anfang von chagall
und jetzt habt könnt ihr alle unterarten
sagen dies hat hier alle pronomen
aufgezählt ich habe das gefühl dass
jetzt jetzt doch das gut dann gehen wir
weiter
mohammed auf dem weg zur aufnahmeprüfung
für die kantonsschule zürich nord für
ihn ist es ein wichtiger tag
sein ziel hat er klar vor augen er will
an die eth an die prüfung geht er mit
einem guten gefühl die nervosität habe
im griff sagt er
ob mohammed die prüfung geschafft hat
wird er in rund zwei wochen erfahren die
chancengleichheit der kinder von
zugewanderten ist jürg schoch ein
anliegen
chancengleichheit ist dann gegeben wenn
jedes kind aus dem was es hat potenzial
hat und was es machen will das auch
umsetzen kann
die kinder sind sehr verschieden begabt
die kinder sind auch sehr
verschiedenartig auch von der motivation
her chancengerechtigkeit wird er heißen
ich bekomme die chance dass aus mir zu
machen was in mir steckt wenn ich es
will die schülerinnen und schüler haben
in verschiedenen gymnasium des kantons
zürich die aufnahmeprüfung abgelegt
einige von ihnen auch am gymnasium
unterstrass stefan march it teilt ihnen
die resultate persönlich mit sicher
nicht also du hast die du hast von 61 0
61 schüler und schülern hast du die 22
auf rang 22
auch die zwillinge franziska victoria
warten gespannt auf den bescheid
jetzt sechs jahre alt ist ist geschafft
so setzt das schein und dann zum singen
also ich glaub so mehr ist neben der
dekoration und zwar recht gut
etwas später studierte
es bestanden haben wir ständig auf den
reset knopf blitz so große sie also wenn
es entschärft
willkommen
das ist doch das schöne kulisse
ja ja eigentlich schon das ganze
[Musik]
sie werden im programm chagall plus noch
durch die probezeit des gymnasiums
begleitet
[Musik]
matthias den brief bekommen
wie ist das schlecht nicht verstand
ich bin enttäuscht ja schon ein bisschen
ich habe sogar schon den nächsten weg
ich werde jetzt sehr wahrscheinlich die
zehnte schuljahr machen
ich werde eine leder suchen nämlich an
die politik mit der schule prüfung
vorbereiten
ich habe die prüfung bestanden da am
freitag aber das iphone im internet
aufgedeckt
überrascht hatte publisher eine 4,05 und
wartete
mir ist ein stein vom herzen gefallen
wie hat deine familie reagiert sie haben
einmal muss man telefonieren mit ihrer
cousine satz gehört dass ich gesagt habe
so bestanden und dann benachrichtigt
in meiner familie in deutschland italien
sie habe wurden für ihre anstrengung
belohnt zum teil mit wirklich noch mal
deutlich besser und zeugnisnoten so
haben mir manch erzählt dass sie bis zu
zehn stunden zusätzlich hausaufgaben
gelöst haben zu hause in den
spitzenzeiten aber sicher immer zwei bis
vier stunden haben sie jede woche noch
zusätzlich zu hause wie sauber
gearbeitet
ich persönlich finde das eine sehr
beträchtliche anstrengung victoria
schaffte den sprung ans gymnasium
kita gelang es nicht sie beginnt nun
eine berufslehre als dental assistentin
[Musik]
von 26 schülerinnen und schülern haben
16 ihr ziel erreicht die mehrheit geht
ihnen gymnasium
andere haben eine lehrstelle gefunden
und setzen ihre ausbildung in einer
berufs- oder fach maturitätsschule vorn
für uns ist das eine der schönsten auch
anspruchsvollsten aber der schönsten und
befriedigenden arbeiten die wir
überhaupt haben junge menschen die sich
bilden wollen die danach lechzen etwas
zu lernen dabei zu unterstützen diesen
weg zu geben und erfolg zu haben ist
enorm befriedigen
[Musik]
[Applaus]